[Music]
and welcome back to careful boys where
we talk about a couple things that we
think is really careful
careful guys careful
we might get canceled
can you edit out what i just didn't say
yes
i was like what was really careful good
job
can you never be too confused
write that down so what can we talk
about then
we could talk about
how mike's a murderer
yeah let's talk about that dude mystery
[ __ ] is hella popular right now bro it's
the hottest [ __ ] ever i don't know when
it's not ever gonna not be popular it's
so fascinating dude i told you guys my
wife watches uh this chick who does her
own makeup while she's like talking
about a murder mystery damn it's killed
did you cover the gabby potito story yet
i don't think so that's gonna be crazy
it's too fresh yeah they're still like
figuring out what happened right isn't
it i thought the details aren't figured
out yet i think what the new thing on
social media with this case is is like
who finds the couf figures out the case
first like that's what
came up with the craziest conspiracy too
exactly because they're sorry
that's what i think wait so he's missing
he's been on the run oh he's on the run
oh [ __ ] he's obviously that that is
technically
what we think i don't think it's
official that's a tick tock says what
would you do how would you do it if i
what if you killed someone like you went
on a date with someone okay and you came
back
how was that date michael at the movie
theater you know i couldn't find her
after
i feel like you would have to get rid of
the body from little what would you do
what would you specifically do killing
oh [ __ ] dude i feel like that's the part
that i like don't feel that comfortable
with so i would definitely hire someone
to do it for me nah dude
nobody believes this is what you do mike
that's what you do you're a swimmer
right okay oh let's go for a swim you're
way more skilled in the water than
probably this person so you use your
water polo skills and then you tug them
down by the ankle then bring them land
choke them out and then they pass away
why you choke them out on land and they
could just enjoy the water you suck at
killing people
why don't you just drown them you choke
them on land you bring them down there
you do mouth-to-mouth in the water like
the movies to make their own you bring
them out and you punch them
that's also another way take them out
and land you beat them up and then and
then you choke them out and then you go
oh they drowned and then you push them
in the water
and then when they do it's just studying
your weaknesses right now
you just gave me an idea
so how about you do this okay you airbnb
a house on the beach that has a port
okay outside house right
you go and you rent a boat
and then uh so you don't go with her so
on the boat manifest only shows one
person okay you bring the boat to that
house dude this guy's right you bring
the boat to the house you have her get
on and she thinks it's romantic
right but there's only one house has a
boat way that's what i said there's a
port and then you have her get on then
you go scuba diving and when you're like
50 feet under
yeah
take off all the other stuff but on the
invoice you're only renting one scooby
[Laughter]
yeah all of that you got to cover all
your tracks hide them neatly
in the uh
in underneath the rocks and then now you
collect 20 lobsters and you bring them
to where she is and hopefully she eat
they eat all the body guess what guess
what then they eat the body parts
whatever and then all the [ __ ] floats
back up to the top you get [ __ ] dead
to rights yeah the stomach broke then
the sharks come and eat it dude you
gotta you gotta clear up the stomach and
trails do you ever see like whales when
they blow up in the water oh yeah or out
of the water yeah out of the water no
that's not stabbing them i'm stabbing
yeah yeah but you're gonna clear the
entrails or the gasses will
bring the body before you go underneath
you chop you chop her up in pieces
in the water first
and good thing you're in the channel
islands where you're like two feet two
two two miles away from the shores do
you go to the marianas trench but that's
the deepest one
here in the trench right
now what's the hardest part of the um of
getting rid of a body is it like the
bones are pretty hard probably the bones
that's why your hair and teeth like
dentures you gotta you gotta get pigs
bro you get them you get a bunch of
bones though yeah
everything dude you'll probably eat a
tin can apparently according to the
movie snatch you just to pull their
teeth out get the pigs starved for like
a couple days or so and you throw the
body in there and they eat it i didn't
let a pig starve though
steve would eat it before it starved so
what about the whole acid thing yeah
yeah it dissolves yeah it dissolves over
a certain amount of time like that
that's too much or what if you borrow
all that home depot yeah those under
yeah
for breaking bad then you [ __ ]
burn her ass underwater underwater
welding underwater like welding kits
what's that well the story is by geo if
you're watching this
his girlfriend uh-huh
right i don't know i feel like um you
could just throw people overboard
that's true the best thing about all
this has been watching mike listen to
you talk and the whole time i want to
it's like editor cut to his face while
he's looking at bart
and it's like internal model like bart
oh simple part all i would have to do
is
make sure that you were working out one
night with a spotter and all of a sudden
your spotter has to go outside to take a
phone call
boom that's actually a very good way or
maybe i would just call the spotter and
then he would drop the thing onto bart
and then boom accident happens but you
have to make sure that you have to make
sure he's going to fail his [ __ ] p.i
never failed never never right michael's
killing strategy is puppet master yeah
michael at bart's funeral he has a
sweatshirt on he's literally beating off
like this
he's like
accidents happen
while i'm coming on my pants
just jacking off that bart's funeral
dude anytime mike's wearing a hoodie i'm
always suspected of him jacking up well
you've got these two together i'm more
like
it's like that one looks lit bro that
one side looks limp
so if mike asked you to go on like a
one-on-one hang would you guys go hell
he's too scared to do it in front of you
or do it to you so i need to deal with
michael at all times mike and another
friend that's why he's here today i
don't know bart joe where does this come
you like have you like murdered somebody
you don't think you don't think he could
murder somebody i think anybody can
murder somebody but like michael
specifically like i think michael
probably can [ __ ] do mass suicide
murder like organization
like something that i like he's handing
out the punch like
i'm not stupid oh you know what's the
most suspicious dude here because it's
always the unlikely guy yeah yeah you
you you suspect always the unlikely one
like like you know you know how a couple
years ago i think mark zuckerberg came
out with that statement where he was
like i'm gonna be vegetarian unless like
kill my own food or something like that
so i thought about that before like
could i go out and uh kill other human
beings no i'm not killing human beings
but go ahead and kill other animals and
zuckerberg actually vegetarian i don't
know if he actually followed through
with it but like that's what he said or
something like that and i mean joe rogan
does it kind of he's like he kills his
own food oh he does yeah because he goes
hunting and stuff oh [ __ ] and so like i
think the only thing that i've ever
killed before i guess i killed um was
mark zuckerberg
and that's why we haven't heard from him
in a while
yeah they all said he moved to kauai
here shut the oysters um which you know
but then the thing that i've done that
was like the most freaky for me was when
i uh cut open live uni
like a sea urchins because it's still
pretty much moving yeah and then you
pretty much have to take like a huge
knife or some sort to like really bash
it open it up no heart sink
my heart sank for a sec because i
thought live looting was a youtuber
like was live looting i killed that
[ __ ]
god damn it
you know first of all i think we got to
be talking about something that has like
[ __ ] eyes
you have to like be able to see
into the gateway of its soul and then
it's like you killed it fish have no
soul for me i'm fine yeah i'll kill any
fish no no sweat yeah the uuni was it
the yellow parts are moving still no not
the yellow parts the spikes are moving
so like when you buy it it's live it's
still moving around and then like it's
moving around and then it's like well i
was like looking at it and thinking like
oh [ __ ] you know well i bought it i
shouldn't just uh you know throw it in
the trash can not eat it obviously right
it's gonna die regardless yeah it's
fresh uni and so i was like all right
one two three and then i took a knife
and then went down and bashed it and
then you split it open halfway there
and i had a pet hermit crab yeah and
that we got at the beach and we put in
like a little terrarium had it for a
couple months and then we decided to let
it go and my dad's taking it out of the
terrarium and we're like on the cliffs
of san diego or whatever and he's taking
it out and then it [ __ ] bites his
hair like clamps his hand his finger and
he goes oh god [ __ ] damage he flicks
it and the thing just flicks and you
hear it like
against a rock and like
we're all just like oh god i think
bart's like [ __ ] dead his name was
bart simpson really oh cool
oh my god
hey were you were you really sad yeah
[ __ ] yeah we were like oh my god but
that's a god [ __ ] dammit
that's hilarious yeah i was at the
monterey bay with my mom and her friends
on like a trip to san francisco and then
i got a bucket full of hermit crabs
and um
i didn't understand like salt water and
all that stuff oh no so we i cleaned the
book and i poured just regular water in
and when these things die the bodies
just come out of the shell
yeah what did you do you you soaked it
with just like hot water
because they couldn't breathe it's
probably what happened so i didn't know
and then i remember looking at the
bucket oh my god and i'm like everyone
came out of their shell to play
but then they just none of them were
moving
and i left it there and then after two
weeks it just smelled really bad scarier
than anything michael said everyone came
out of their shells to play
well play
he's like did i say herman i'm at a
school bus with children
i feel like what's the next step and
that story is like your mom took it and
sauteed it or something into like black
bean sauce
that's disgusting vegetarian oh that's
right i forgot of my bad
green bean sauce
that's [ __ ] like my dad probably
would have done it yeah
because that's what happened to julia
right like she had a pet turtle or
something and then her grandma her
grandma made turtles no way for real
wow that's fun that's hardcore speaking
of turtles remember how i was talking
about with the with lawrence earlier
that we worked at the sushi restaurant
called sakana yeah so like right outside
that sushi restaurant i was in la canada
um there was one of those really nice
looking asiany style uh fountain water
things that had like a little bit of
fish but mainly they had turtles there
those like you know red ear sliders yeah
is that what they're called yeah that's
the fat one but it's one that you like
illegally get from like chinatown but
they grow up to be like this big right
you're sliders
but people eat those too okay well like
bart's dad so you sound like okay maybe
it was bart's dad you did this but so we
used to have like maybe like seven eight
of them that would just you know at
night you would lock up but the the
fountain area would just be outside and
then one morning we'd come back into
work to open up the restaurant and
literally
turtles would be uh
out crushed shells
and amputated like legs and heads and
they would just be like somebody came
and butchered oh that's [ __ ] somebody
did it or an animal
no no like it's like a human being with
tools yeah like cut the [ __ ]
arms and legs and like crushed like
crushed the imagine taking a chill and
just crushing it right and it happened
to like one or two of them and we were
like dude this is a sick weird single
incident right but then when it happened
like three or four days later again
we're like so he's [ __ ] coming to
murder turtles so every night we had to
take the turtle yeah but there's no
cameras you guys could have tried to
catch the time the turtle killer man
that's [ __ ] you have to do a stinger
operation that's so [ __ ] up do you
think it would be illegal if
you guys waited and when they came and
grabbed the turtle you grabbed him and
decapitated his arms and crushed his
[ __ ] yeah yeah he would probably be able
to court a lot it's okay
what state are we in
florida people like michael should be in
jail for this kind of [ __ ] dude i can't
believe you [ __ ] did that he's all
playing off like oh my god that's so
terrible
what's the really the worst thing you've
ever done
that is one of the worst or that is one
of the most intense things that i have
done i feel like the worst i i i can't i
can't even tell it on this channel
because it's gonna get me arrested
remember this is careful boys terrible
that's true hey way to be careful
actually
way to be careful that's [ __ ] up
because if he was doing that to make
turtle soup later that's fine but for
pleasure fine is all still [ __ ] weird
you're just mutilating them from just
mutilating i can't even think about that
no that's so [ __ ] up because turtles
are so cute who doesn't like turtles
turtles are my favorite i feel like it
starts there and this [ __ ] is
gonna be the guy that does these creepy
things and like becomes a serial killer
that turtle was like the gateway
murderer yeah that's like that's gateway
it seems like get some dexter [ __ ] you
know actually hey again don't [ __ ] with
cats you don't watch
it's gateway [ __ ] dude that's how it
goes
also murderers they always start
somewhere michael how many teddy bears
have you owned where you took out one of
the eyeball and you put a camera on the
back of that side of the eyeball
too many to remember and then like how
many years were you too many places to
remember what a good answer that's a
great answer there this guy's good
damn dude that makes me feel like the
worst thing is we can't [ __ ] phase
the guy yeah we could light him up for
two weeks and that and that's why we
know he's the perfect serial murderer
dude
like ted bundy was like that you could
say anything to the guy he's like you
know he had a great excuse he's very
charming michael's very charming as well
you are very ted bundy
he's a charming man
i was gonna say something but i decided
probably shouldn't say just say it say
it come on come on you're not really
like ted bundy yeah you're ted bundy
light he's probably like i'm better than
temp buddy
ted buddy was a [ __ ] idiot
his internal monologue is like you guys
are scared of crushed turtles
[Laughter]
just [ __ ] wait what is this amateur
hour [ __ ] dude for that for that one
um just kidding party game like it was
like you basically have like a box i
think you guys all played it and then
you put your hands inside and then to
see like what's in there um
one of the items that we were you know
thinking about were was or actually it
wasn't with your neighbor's fingers no
no no or so like um i didn't know what
items we were gonna pick and uh so we
had all so basically we had all like the
one a lot of them locked down but there
was like one or two that you know we
could still switch up at the last moment
and so to pick the items i went to the
chinese grocery store early in the
morning oh you can find all kinds of
[ __ ] you can find a lot of stuff and um
one of the things that i saw was like a
live frogs right live stuff
and uh i was thinking like it'd be
really fun
maybe i mean they're they're kind of
cute and they're like pets right to have
squishy like oh what the [ __ ] is that
feel good though what would you do with
the recognition i know what chimpanzee
i remember so yeah we had a prep group
and then i remember texting anyone going
like well does anyone want like a frog
as a pet or are they gonna use it to eat
or something i used to have a frog for a
pet
you're texting a bunch of asian people
anybody my pet or
lunch
what did aunt say i'm curious what aunt
said and i don't think ann was in that
discussion then because like that was
right when he had come in um but geo was
like no hell no i don't want to deal
with that she doesn't want to [ __ ] with
animals but at the same time she also
took the rats that we had for just
kidding party as well oh that's why we
had them yes we had [ __ ] pet rats in
our house for like two years or some
[ __ ] no way yeah
and this is where we're living in our uh
place in downtown we had this giant [ __ ]
so we had these stupid rats
they're meant to die right they're meant
to be fed to a snake yeah they're stupid
were they kind of cute
but they're not meant to be pet rats
they're meant to be fed to like snakes
and [ __ ] damn she came along with rats
we ended up buying this 300 [ __ ] cage
so that the rat has like multiple
stories of [ __ ] live and in and then
these rats since they're like mass bred
after about like a few months you start
feeling these little tumors for them oh
they're not really genetically like
optimized you know it's crazy they end
up passing away but we bought all kinds
of toys and like every day like after
she would open like an amazon package
she would like cut it in cute shapes oh
this would be a house for the rat and
the house i'm in the [ __ ] rat like
like dig little holes she's like i'm
tired of kids
thank you for the thank you for this toy
but i would like some kind of cancer
treatment would be really nice i guess
i shouldn't do something losing fur oh
my god you actually gave it like rat
chemo and [ __ ] you would have had some
testicles running around oh my god well
i'm glad those rats got to have a better
life and they probably would have been
fed to a snake slowly die
[Laughter]
better than being snake food man yeah i
could because i feel like as snake feel
what you do sometimes is you have to
like bash them on the head or something
yeah otherwise they're gonna hurt your
uh your snakes because they'll scratch
and bite i heard that casey was telling
me they had to do that and i was like
this is [ __ ] up yup like he told me he
would put him in a bag and then he would
spin the bag around and then you would
slam it onto the encounter or something
this is the thing because you want to
stun them but at the same time you need
to kind of disorient them as well so how
many times have you done this
that's why you got to make sure that
you're like yeah
a few times
yeah what's up with the spinning like
why can't you just [ __ ] pow put in a
bag here to lash the top over put a
couple pellets on the inside so if it
shakes around i i may be messing up the
story a little bit but like you know
what it could have been and he was
topless with a [ __ ] cowboy hat on
mike dude why do you tell us all these
like weird like fun facts about killing
stuff
you have all these weird fun facts
do you have a um a sex tape a sexy
no i i do not i do not have a sex tape
but um i feel like i've seen you as i
said maybe
neck down
had a massage porn star that looks like
michael
wait really oh it's like a amateur night
look him up yeah can you can you show me
him
there's it's like an interracial couple
i want to be inspired by myself is what
it is
pacino's
adventures
step brother it's just interesting yeah
your uh your character is sleepwalking
into the room while she's on the phone
and then has sex with her she goes oh my
god my brother's in my freaking vagina
vagina
dude stevie weeby what a creep huh
[ __ ] pacino's adventures
is this the real thing yes
he was showing us his favorite porns
dude we gotta get him back he's the best
you weren't here but like stevie was
telling us his like top three favorite
porn tuk tuk patrol yeah
that's right pacino's adventures and
then something else
i think i've seen clips for the tuk-tuk
patrol it's not one of my favorites but
i don't know what uh what so you're
familiar with tucked up oh the grandma
one he liked the grandma the grandma
grandma the mature granny creepers
they're all they're they all
float around the equator
yeah i can't be messing with no
grandma's that was the last like off the
record we did and then we're like yo
dude we can't talk about whatever we
want to be careful boys
wait wait that's off the record that
wasn't off the record oh my god yeah
we're all watching i was pulling up the
porno over there straight up it was sick
yeah it was sick it was dope because you
know you it's it's interesting to see
what other people watch you know yeah
it's fun it's fun it's swaps
it's also fun to like go back to junior
high where you're like a bunch of dudes
are sitting down around one you're
watching porno
and then trying to find your boners yeah
now all i watch is potatoes
i always wondered who are the guys that
like the grandma porn and i finally
found someone and i was like oh i found
one
i need to try to find i didn't find two
also he told us the story that all i
won't say but uh because i'm gonna be
careful boy but
it was pretty great
hey we all know the story wait no
it on patreon no it was it was uh
it was off the record it was definitely
off the record
you